people of the internet retro Records who
are here I'm just a dad who loves games
and the stories they tell and it seems
like we are closer than ever to the
Harry Potter magic awakened release I
know I know stop me if you've heard it
before right we have definitely been in
this position before but from everything
I'm seeing everything I'm reading it
definitely sounds like this release is
imminent to us here in the U.S and our
friends over in the UK everywhere else
basically it seems like already has the
game at least in a limited capacity
however there are a couple things you
could do right now to get ready
including a brand new one that they just
revealed on the website earlier today
and I gotta say I'm a little bit
disappointed with it so on the Harry
Potter magic awakened website there is
an event ongoing that says Harry Potter
magic awakened wand testing so I'm gonna
walk you guys through it here I'm going
to show you the whole entire test
spoiler alert it's very very short and
also a note here you cannot do this on
desktop at least I could not figure out
a way to do so there's a little QR code
you have to scan and then you do it on
your mobile device okay here we go
entering the Olive and years
and let's see oh it does have music but
copyright so no music no music welcome
to olivander's Wand Shop dude the thing
about this game the art style is just so
striking okay first we need a username
all right retro rack and tour email says
email is optional leave your email to
receive your personalized wand after the
game launched all right and then it just
says select your favorite color and
submit you only have four options red
green blue or yellow okay I'm torn here
because clearly they're representing the
four houses my house is Gryffindor but
my favorite color is blue surely this is
not it right it's gonna lead into more
all right I'm just gonna pick blue and
then we're gonna submit this username
has already been taken bruh excuse me
how is this username already been taken
all right well I guess somebody stole my
username what I'm wondering is if it is
somehow pulling from the
pre-registration because I did
re-register with that name I definitely
didn't do this wand part and it didn't
have any option of logging in or
anything I can't do retro Rec Couture
can't do retro underscore rack and tour
can't do retro wrecking tour five so I'm
gonna say retro raconteur 50. this
username has already been taken okay I
think the website might not be working
properly yet because there's no way that
somebody has that username okay I just
tried retro and for some reason that
worked I have no idea why retro
raconteur 50 is apparently taken but
just retro wasn't so we're good we got
our wand so I got uh black walnut swishy
nine and three fourths unicorn hair
this versatile one is attracted to a
highly intelligent Master click to view
my wand file okay so that was it man
that
just asked for a name for an email and
your favorite color there was really no
other questions at all it did not pull
it's kind of weird why would it not just
pull from what we already have on the
Wizarding World website that I don't
understand the owner retro black walnut
wands are drawn to extremely talented
innovators of magic representative Bella
wands made from unicorn hairs produce
the most consistent magic they are
extremely faithful to their owners
regardless of whether they are
accomplished or not okay so then we have
event information June 2nd uh 2023
through June 26th this is a
pre-registration commemorative event
enter your name and email to enter the
Ollivander wand shop and test your wand
after completing the full process a
redemption code will be sent to the
participating email for redemption in
the game after it is launched important
reminders each email account can only
test the wand once if you want to
confirm the one result you have tested
please try with the previously used
email yeah I don't understand why I
wouldn't just pull your wand from The
Wizarding World I have a totally
different wand on that website and that
one actually you know takes your answers
into account way more than just what's
your favorite color so on there I'm
Beechwood Phoenix core 12 and 1 4
unbending flexibility now the other
thing you can do if you haven't already
is you can pre-register for the game
whether you're on iOS Android or PC and
by doing this as a community we can
unlock more in-game rewards when the
game finally releases they actually just
tweeted on June 2nd we're so honored to
reach 2 million signups from players
eager to enjoy Harry Potter magic
awakened at Global launch this summer
again committing to the this summer The
2 million reward tiers Awards players
100 gems plus 2 000 gold let's keep this
momentum going for 5 million signups to
earn one golden key and 50 gems now I
haven't played the game yet so I have no
idea what these things actually do in
the game however from talking to some
people who actually have played it it
sounds like they're pretty significant
so we want to try and push for that 8
million reward which we currently don't
even know what it is now one of the
strange things about magic awaken is
just how quiet it has been for this game
here in the US and I think one of the
biggest problems is this sort of mixed
messaging we have if you guys didn't
know there are actually two official
websites at least I think they're both
official for this there's
magicawakened.com and then there's also
Harry Potter magic awakened in fact if
you go to magicawaken.com and you scroll
to the bottom of the page here over in
the bottom right you'll see for more
information about Harry Potter magic
awakened please visit Harry Potter
magicwaken.com so I think what's going
on here is the magic awakened site is
the one set up by WB whereas the Harry
Potter magic awakened slash Global by
the way if you want to see it in English
it's very very strange there are also
two YouTube channels so I'm gonna be
getting to the bottom of this and
putting together a video with all the
details you need to know for Harry
Potter magic awaken as soon as I have
that ready I'll link it on the right
side of your screen as always guys thank
you all so much for watching I'll talk
to you again soon